[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
à
donne moi de l'argent y avait longtemps
à écoutes ne dispute pas j'ai besoin
d'argent tout de suite mais ça devient
une manie tu vas tout le temps besoin
d'argent vous avez tout un besoin parce
que je n'en ai jamais oui ton
portefeuille mon veston s'il te plaît
peux-tu remettre mon veston il était sur
le dossier du fauteuil ou et fric toute
ma fortune est entre tes mains
safran et 43 centimes de monnaies
puisque ticket de métro
mais thierry tu plaisantes jamais sur
les questions d'argent d'un sujet qu'il
ne pousse guère à plaisanter je t'assure
mais quand j'ai quitté ce matin dans les
buts 1 100 francs les voilà quoi une
machine à écrire pour quoi faire
devine taper dessus mais ça s'appelle
écrire et qu'est ce que tu veux écrire
un scénario
une idée j'allais à la vois tu vas
interrompue enfin on se tient déjà du
typhon c'est l'essentiel
je trouve que tu aurais fait d'avoir un
peu plus que le titre pour t'acheter une
machine à écrire ans je pense que je me
prive de tout les 300 francs que je t'ai
donné avant qu'une sorte à je suis allé
sur x 300 francs de coiffeur et ben
voila frais thiery c'est épouvantable
une fois du monde ils feront tout de
suite tu me dis ça à moi soit bien je ne
les ai pas grand fan jury c'est pas
possible tout le monde a dit romain
honte pour nous et d'autres sans taj
d'intermédiaire sur la boîte à nous sous
la grande catherine la faire à claques
tesfran a su très bien expliqué que je
faisais là ben oui à découvert en mai
cerfeuil
comment est ce qu'on va vivre mais comme
d'habitude mais d'abord pourquoi tu
brusquement tellement besoin de 10
francs c'est ridicule différent oui
c'est que c'est ridicule n'empêche qu'il
me les faut tout de suite demain je te
les trouverait dommage
l'un des dj de virton chan et géraldine
tu commences à me fatiguer 1
alors tu prends ces cinq francs 43
centimes tulle et dilatés data ghz
ce n'est pas un sou de plus à offrir que
veux tu que je fasse avec 5 points 40,3
centimes que je dois 10 et jeudi 10 mai
d'avis que nous sommes en train de
discuter ça doit faire 12 bientôt 15 et
20 euros la nuit tout ça ce terme et
remblais en bloc
ah oui figure-toi lucio firth est
impatiente quel chauffeur celui du taxi
qui attend en vain quoi attaque si oui
comment début du circuit en hélicoptère
bref on sait se débrouiller pas besoin
de taxi on tombe des gens autour des
voitures et qui vous conduisent merci
pour le conseil ils étaient tous pris
aujourd'hui aux îles au pluriel
tu préfères le singulier l'eau on te
demande pas de comptes ma chérie je te
fais confiance
l'ennui c'est que je commence à avoir
une réputation de fans fidèles dans
paris c'est mauvais mais jusqu'à présent
tout on est toujours bien tiré
comme avec ton conserver ouais vous avez
pourquoi crois tu qu'il nous est prêté
son appartement ton cousin hervé penses
tu partais six mois pour le canada et il
a l'esprit de famille
ah parce qu'ils espéraient surtout
qu'avant son départ je viendrai lui
rendre visite
seul nom oui elle est gonflée le cousin
et bien tu dit qu'on verrait surtout mon
pied aux fesses oui en fait tu as bien
fait d'une pac décourager complètement
en attendant qu'est ce qu'on fait on est
chez hervé on irait taxi il fallait
surtout pas le perdre
et si je téléphonais a dit à quelqu'un
qui nous prêtera d'argent et qui nous
invitera dîner
quelque chose doit ce soir non plus
oui mais voilà quelqu'un at il envie
nous avons dansé de l'argent et en plus
de nous inviter à dîner pour un petit
zoo a essayé je vais faire ça
méthodiquement
alors mon calepin ses téléphones
c'était un simple jean charles et 12,1
depuis quand hier on s'est vraiment pas
de chance on va chasser le til death
montrer la même jusqu'à lundi paraît un
peu long pour faire attendre le taxi
hamon qu'est ce que tu penses d'armand
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas tapé
celui-là malheureux tout c'est bien
qu'il ait ruinée ruiné ses patrons sont
argentines ne peut plus sortir un sou au
mexique et il a sur les bras en plus
pauvres armand j'aiderai devises
étrangères se raréfient et si je fais
peter hahn hon pas peter la bocca della
bitter il est fou de moi après la façon
dont il abat fois l'autre soir en
sortant de chez castel qu'est ce que
j'ai fait tu l'a traité ignominieusement
oyane de place dans sa vie
justement la tienne était tout désigné à
côté de lui c'est toi qui t'y émis mais
parce que tu es parti avec tony conte
avec tony awards ne vais rien à craindre
or les poids très délicate vis-à-vis de
ce pauvre peter y avait de castres et
toulouse de toute la soirée on était
gêné une sensibilité mon cher j'aurais
bien bob loiseau oh là là bob loiseau et
ses histoires drôles pourquoi va
probablement ça y est
le téléphone est coupé coupé tu l'as pas
payer un battant je vais me geraldine
qu'est-ce que tu es fait avec l'argent
du téléphone figure toi que j'étais sur
le point de me rendre à la poste quand
tout d'un coup on sonne à la porte alors
par distraction je vais ouvrir les
folles je me trouve une fois de plus
face à face avec un casque en
électricité alors qu'est ce que tu
voulais je fasse lui a fermé la porte au
nez
mais c'était le dernier avertissement si
je ne paye pas y couper le courant
mais qu'est ce qu'ils ont tous
aujourd'hui à couper le courant
j'ai pensé qu'il valait mieux c'est
quelqu'un de téléphone c'est absurde
parce que faute d'électricité emploie
toujours ce éclairé aux bougies en
mixant téléphone on est fichu le
téléphone c'est notre est souvent de
travail
van eeuwen du bistrot du coin non tu
peux pas le chauffeur celui du taxi qui
t'attend au bas mot à dire si le
chauffeur tiens c'est tragique
nous sommes coincés dans l'immeuble
isolé du reste du monde en plein 16
10ème arrondissement mais pendant ce
temps là le compteur tourne on a sonné
j'en suis sûr si dieu est
vraisemblablement oui faisons les morts
tu me met vraiment dans des situations
geraghty l'année oui on a sonné je ne
vois pas il finira bien par se lasser
là où pas rameuté tout l'immeuble pas si
tu t'en rends compte mon chou mais
l'ambiance que tu crées autour de toi
n'est pas précisément favorable à
l'inspiration théâtrale mais la défense
est là bas ça c'est possible
ces immeubles modernes c'est de la
camelote monde actif dans la chambre on
se débrouille toi une femme seule c'est
toujours préférable dans ces cas là
mais s'il te manquer de respect je suis
à côté un surtout n'hésite pas à me
déranger
merci eh bien à mon amie on voit là une
façon d'entrer chez les gens une seconde
de plus et ça faisait sauter le temps de
venir
je suppose que vous voulez votre argent'
way et sans baratin j'ai assez perdu de
temps comme ça eh bien vous avez la voir
inutile de vous mettre dans des états
pareils vous avez les yeux d'une sorte
de la tête entrant 50 quand je ne
discuterai pas pourquoi j'aurais quand
même vendu à point c'est tout vous êtes
dans votre droit le plus absolu ce que
je désapprouve messieurs ce sont vos
procédés écouté ma ptite dame
mon dîner matin ma femme aussi et va
s'inquiéter
j'habite à saint thois c'est pas la
porte à côté les toiles et les
boulevards extérieurs vous y atteint 5
minutes
je vous signale que la rue alfred jarry
encore changé de sens unique
maintenant c'est le mauvais qu'ils
vendent ce fabas propre m'embêter par
seul marché disent que vous êtes déjà un
retard
je ne veux pas vous retenir davantage
écrivez-moi la bia lisiblement votre nom
et votre adresse
je ne serai pas revenir ma petite tête
par voie postale demain matin ses
premiers j'aime pas qu'on soute deux
bagages sortie chauffeur ne vous mettez
pas en colère je vous en conjure
laissez moi vous expliquer un agent je
vais chercher un agent voix lui
expliquerai à lui vous êtes mariés vous
savez que vous allez comprendre je suis
sûr que vous allez tout compris je
comprends que vous profitez d'un honnête
homme et vous n'avez pas d'argent pour
le payer et bien oui c'est vrai je vous
montre à vous voyez je n'ai pas d'argent
c'est vrai bon bah quand on n'a pas
d'argent on ne prend pas de taxis
je suis une étourdi j'aurais dû vérifier
dans sa cage aurait dû à bas je n'ai pas
voilà aussi j'espérais que mon mari
serait de retour à la maison qui vous
réglerait seulement voilà il n'est pas
là où droit je n'entre pas dans ces
considérations là qu'est ce que vous
faites
je me stein c'est une violation de
domicile
ne vous gênez pas surtout voie gauche
toujours ma belle tu m'intéresses si
vous ne sortez pas immédiatement dit si
j'avais le ski vous ne croyez pas
capable et je le fais je compte jusqu'à
3-3 j'entends l'ascenseur c'est
peut-être votre mari oui vous monsieur
excusez-moi de vous êtes en train
d'écouter
sur le palier sans vous connaître mais
je me trouve dans une situation ridicule
vous seul pouvez m'en citer monsieur moi
oui j'irai droit au but il faut que vous
me prêtez 10 francs ah bon mais à quel
fait trop mal à outils titre de la
solidarité humaine monsieur on m'a
arraché aux griffes de cette brutes
avinées qu'ils exercent sur moi un
odieux chantage non non non taisez-vous
enfin ban comment serait-il monsieur je
suis au bord de la dépression nerveuse
c'est sans condition et sans explication
qu'il me les foires bon très bien alors
madame dans ces conditions vous sera
remboursé bien sûr par mon mari que
j'attends d'un resto
oui c'est que malheureusement je je n'ai
qu'un billet de 100 francs alors bon un
billet de 100 francs
et naturellement c'est à moins d'avoir
la monnaie tous les maires 1 2 3 6 7 8 9
centres de composition les chauffeurs de
taxi a mis ainsi va la garder ça vous
les méritez pas un
je ne veux pas vous encombrer de tous
ces billets poisson
je dois donc s'offre un compte rond
c'est plus un bon très bien ma maman est
un bon championnat et sarah kenna vieux
cochon bons mots
[Applaudissements]
comme en remercie non mais je vous en
prie madame vous avez tout le monde à ma
place
hélas non messieurs la galanterie est
une qualité qui se perdent et encore
d'une génération qui ça non enfin je
veux dire
le hasard fait bien les choses je
revenais chez le médecin qui avait
justement j'en reçois même pas lire béni
soit dans votre médecin si vous n'êtes
pas mal non non vous savez simples
visites de prévention à mon âge il faut
se surveiller à tout âge eh bien il me
reste plus qu'à vous remercier une fois
de plus c'est vous êtes montre un peu
plus complaisant au revoir monsieur nous
permettait madame oui mais voici ma
carte
si votre mari préféré me régler par
chèque postal voici le numéro de mon
message est complètement vide ça n'est
pas grave je vous en prie ton des
dommages
[Applaudissements]
thierry thierry tu veux sortir déjà
parti regardes tu vas soutirer sa au
chauffeur de taxi n'était pas atteint
690 balle
géraldine c'est génial je dois dire que
je ne suis pas médecin mais pas juste
quelqu'un qui n'est pas juste que nous
qui avons tant besoin d'argent
nous en ayons si peu mon rêve d'être oui
comment faire quand on est né sans os ou
que l'on a en tout cas l'espoir
d'héritage et qu'on a fait la bêtise
d'épouser une jeune fille sans doute
sans dot pape ait amiral j'avais préféré
mois d'intervalle bon évidemment à lui
aussi s'est passé totti a choisi la
mauvaise voie pour ce qui est des rentre
je me mets la ceinture tu vois où ça les
mène aucun travail de nos jours nous
rapporte vraiment de l'argent je parle
de l'argent avec un a majuscule pas de
médias croates nettement de chef de
bureau
il ya ceux qui ont de l'argent et ceux
qui n'en ont pas et ceux qui n'en ont
pas sont justement ceux qui travaillent
oui enfin si tu étais à la tête d'une
usine au chirurgien amadou quoi faire on
aurait un peu plus calmes en a dix
points devant nous mais je ne demande
pas mieux que de diriger une usine mois
salon coiffure
est-ce qu'on me l'offre est ce qu'on en
donne la chance non je t'assure que
c'est décourageant pour les jeunes je me
demande si on ne devrait pas réduire
notre avis pourquoi tu veux faire faire
des économies et nos amis puisque ce
sont eux qui cassent très juste or il ya
dix dont la propos me demande quelle
tête préserver s'il apprenait que sont
bernard buffet avait disparu de
l'appartement où tu sais pour un bernard
diffèrent
n'empêche que ça fait un vide voilà on a
tout le temps de récupérer à propos tu
vois autre chose à mettre au clou le
bouddha à l'oeuf rigide elle est facile
à déménager seul
la concierge et puis 10 dont tu oublies
cocktail ça fait au moins six mois qu'on
en a pas donné
si ça continue comme ça les gens
finiront par croire qu'on est fauché
qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi c'est
la gamme d'outils qui m'a prêté les 100
francs ping de pau le pauvre ah oui ce
qualificatif me paraît plutôt mal et lui
convenir
pourquoi tu connais qui s rahouli
d'achat tu le connais les tuyaux mais
quelle tuyaux tous les deux jours les
petits les grands les moyens les tuyaux
d'orgue de cette cheminée chauffage
central
l'état nous dégoût les tuyaux droit les
tuyaux coût des longs le gaz électricité
téléphone sans parler du reste tous dans
la france entière est une bonne partie
de l'étranger passe par les tuyaux gâcha
un vrai à une grosse grosse galère le
colossal galets j'ai lu et irrigue son
frein je veux rattraper au tournage je
suis au tuyau au fond qu'est-ce que tu
fais je gâte
il est chez son médecin il va pas tarder
à sortir toi naturellement tu technique
ça à bon régime en a profité pour aller
chercher les journaux du soir et
rapportés des bouteilles vides chez
l'italien
ça nous fera toujours une petite rentrée
d'argent ne se regarde pas trop vite il
a l'air dur à la détente
mais noël devant le marchand de
télévision c'est l'heure des programmes
a tout de suite moins d'argent surtout
géraldine ne le ratent pas inquiète pas
avoir peur c'est un nom - monsieur on a
écouté cette fois madame je suis désolé
mais je suis sorti de chez moi avec très
peu d'argent de poche et je suis dans
l'impossible
mais font des messieurs je n'aurais pas
eu deux fois pareil danse vous rendez ma
confusion extrême
non au contraire tu voulais vous dire
que mon mari venait de me téléphoner
il sera ici d'un instant à l'autre et je
vais pouvoir m'a quitté ma dette envers
ceux de draka pour une si petite chose
madame sur la nuance est facile mais si
que voulez vous l'idée de devoir de
l'argent à quelqu'un me rend
littéralement malade ça devient une idée
fixe à ce point et oui je sais c'est
pathologique
vous avez bien une minute à la vérité je
suis déjà en retard voudriez vous qu'à
cause de vous je passe ses nuits
blanches à cause de moi
et oui je sens que si vous n'êtes pas
remboursée dès ce soir je ne fermerai
pas là et de l'année
alors madame ne va pas tel argument je
m'en voudrais trop merci messieurs
prenez ce fauteuil selmiya
merci cinq minutes vous savez je ne
restera que cinq minutes car si vous
avez la maladie de régler vos dettes
gemmois celle de l'exactitude
nous sommes deux maniaques et oui nous
sommes faits pour nous entendre avec mes
skis non merci dans la même tente et pas
je ma peau certaines règles il manque
parfois de les observer
je vous sers parce que je suis aussi
très têtu monsieur c'est ce qui nous
arrive
il ya plus de whisky aux attentes et
vous avez rien à voir on parle à tous
ça ne fait rien je fume très peu alors
je ne sais plus monsieur
alors monsieur n'ai besoin de rien mais
je suis très bien ainsi je vous assure
vous êtes gentille
nous avons certainement des tas d'amis
comme à croyez-vous agence issue mais je
ne suis pas encore présenter madame
thierry laval
et vous vous êtes le formidable raoult
ligue à chaque jour un formidable je
vous fais juste l'un des magnats de
l'industrie européenne voyez enfin c'est
d'ailleurs que nous vendons aussi pas
mal en amérique du sud
le roi du tuyau mon dieu oui madame
je me sens tout à fait l'idée pas par
moi j'espère par tous ces tuyaux qui
s'incarne en as alors tabler l'étudiant
seront toujours des pions habana vérité
je n'y ai jamais songé et bien moi je
suis reconnaissante à tous les gens
comme vous qui travaillent ou bien être
et au confort de leurs semblables
vous êtes un bienfaiteur de l'humanité
merci madame entre une jeune femme aussi
sensible aux tuyaux vous y étiez
sûrement tout ça au souper devenir
ambassades d'italie en juin dernier
après le concert de la petite armada
je n'ai jamais eu l'honneur d'être
invité à l'ambassade dit alliés je n'ai
jamais eu le plaisir d'entendre la
patate à la patate il a pas tort
ben oui madame je vous le dise cette
fois j'y suis marica tout le monde au
moins une fois dans sa vie à dîner chez
marie cann ce pas marica qui marie
cabrio la seule l'unique marica c'est
sans doute le nom d'un petit restaurant
à la mode
bon je vois monsieur que vous vivez très
retirer au ca on ne peut plus vous savez
je suis un nous avez raison moss au fond
je déteste le monde annonce voyez moi je
ne le déteste pas je ne le connais pas
évitez le monsieur éviter le vous seriez
bien déçu oui n'y a aucun risque âgées
en fin de vie des plus simples c'est
admirable madame d'achat on doit vous
secondes et beaucoup j'imagine je suis
veuf
je suis désolé mais s'est excusé moi mon
nom podium savatan
enfin cela n'en est pas moins triste oui
moi aussi faire
c'est égal vous devez vous sentir bien
seul parfois j'ai une fille très gentil
pour moi et de charmants petits enfants
je suis d'ailleurs invité chez elle à
dîner ce soir j'aimerais bien arriver
avant le pain de mon petit fils patrick
quels sacrifices au nom si on le gagne
tous les jours vous savez pour y
penserait qu'il pourrait retourner
demain soit ou non et puis les 5 minutes
sont écoulées depuis longtemps alors non
non non non rester encore mon mari ne
peut plus tard dit mme bah oui mais
madame c'est l'heure des embouteillages
de grâce à la bonne heure et bien moi
voyez vous monsieur je n'ai pas de petit
enfant à la moindre petit fils mais il
fallut pour ça vous y prendre de très
bonne heure
ah oui enfin je veux dire je n'ai pas
d'enfants volés on va ça vient
je vous le demande
c'est à monsieur la valette qu'il
conviendrait de le demander oui
évidemment pas oui évidemment on m'a dit
vous avez déjà dû y penser
pardon en quelques instants nous sommes
presque déjà aux confidences
oui c'est pourtant par l'iphone qui nous
a déjà eu la parole il me revois ne
serait ce pas plutôt le commencement
d'une amitié monsieur dont la cote est
madame là je crois que moquer pourquoi
moi parce que ça serait vraiment très
rapide alors rapide
disons foudroyant un violent un
irrésistible un incroyable élan donc
qu'est-ce que vous oui bah écoute et
j'en suis très flatté voyez-vous mais
encore plus surpris parce que nous ne
sommes vraiment pas de la même
génération
je fais la mienne comme tous ses petits
muscles pilier de bar dépourvu de sens
moral et parasites de la société
cette jeunesse décadente entre la
recherche d'un idéal fait sourire ah non
monsieur je ne me sens pas des leurs
enfin ils ne sont pas tous comme vous
dites tous avaient heureusement mais
donc je ne sois pas n'y en ait pas plus
d'ailleurs je déteste les jeunes
lesquels aja dont monsieur la valette
justement vous venez de mettre le doigt
sur le point sensible
ah bon ben je le retire
laissez-nous mon mari il est charmant
remarquer on ne peut pas lui en vouloir
il est trop charmant mon mari monsieur
n'est pas ce qu'il devrait être
écoutez madame je préférais que vous ne
m'ayez pas avant déboires conjugaux si
monsieur si ça me fait du bien j'ai
besoin de confier à vous si vous croyez
vous que ce soit prêt nécessaire oui je
me sens tout d'un coup si seuls six
abandonnées bah oui mais alors mon enfin
je voudrais tout d'un coup à bout là
qu'est ce qui se passe
vous avez une petite dispute avec votre
mari monsieur oui mais plus grave dans
quel sens si je le savais seulement
enfin que vous est il fait on m'a fait
qu' il m'a fait que j'ai croisé un homme
mais vous savez votre femme vous naissez
adultes alors il il faut plus de temps
un homme bon là devenir voyons monsieur
vous n'avez pas l'air de bp non ça j'ai
pas l'herbe à bp je n'ai jamais l'air va
vb d'ailleurs même bébé alors messieurs
[Musique]
alors un peu de patience vous avez la
maturité bien ma vie avec l'âge avec les
soucis ne veut plus attendre
j'en peux plus d'attendre j'ai besoin
d'être guidés rassuré vie mais vous vous
exalté n'envoyons invite moi je compte
renouveler bien sûr je vous comprends on
a un petit coeur sensible on on avoue
devrait consoler on sait bien les pas
monsieur non pas si bien que ça vous
êtes charmant monsieur mais vous allez
me faire réfléchir quand j'étais petite
fille est amoureuse de mon papa ah bon
mais c'est freud y ans alors foutez vous
rappelez vous tout mon papa vraiment
elle m'a bien savoir où j'en suis moi
non mais je vais vous poser tout de
suite une question chère seriez-vous par
hasard me séduire
moi oui parce que autant vous répondre
tout de suite si c'est là votre
intention me séduire vous sera plus
facile ici parce que vous êtes
ravissante et si je ressemble votre papa
me ressemblait pas du tout à ma fille
alors autant vous dire que les
sentiments que vous éveillez en moins
lente absolument rien de paternel j'ai
bien compris ma oui certainement je me
rends compte de tout le ridicule qu'un
tel aveu peut avoir dans la bouche d'un
homme de mon âge mais votre coquetterie
votre attitude vous en prie messieurs
qu'avez-vous bien dû imaginer
je me demande moi même alors là
je vous prie de m'en excuser son tissu
cruellement déçus comment avez vous pu
interpréter mon désarroi d'une façon
aussi rabaissante au géant au nom faux
pas faux pas c'est moi qui je ne me suis
pas rendu coup j'ai plus récent retrait
poule
j'étais si loin de penser à tout ça
monsieur pardonnez moi je vous pardonne
si vous me promettez d'être sage
ah bah je peux toujours promettre alors
je vous permets de mamita du nez merci
et quand tout de suite ce soir ce soir
mais votre mari rentrera-t-il seulement
comment comment je croyais que vous avez
téléphoné c'est même pour l'attendre que
je suis encore là moi ah oui c'est vrai
il m'avait dit qu'il allait rentrer mais
je vous voyais tout le moins qu'il n'est
plus là non où s'est-il encore attardé
si on est là mon fort ce soir bah oui
mais non couvert et michel f
non ça fait rien je vais lui téléphoner
pour me les commandes
ben voyons y a pas de courant se
trouvait ça arrive quelquefois non y'a
rien ça je vous assure j'ai toujours
quand on m'appelle pour la wii finirait
bien par me me plaindre a l'a compris
mais ça n'a pas d'importance je fais un
saut chez ma fille je repars vous
prendre dans nimporte un minute un visa
j'adore l'ascenseur c'est précis mon
mari alors là notre petite inès messi
messi a quand même ne dit rien
revenez me prend excuse moi ma chérie
mais je sors d'un conseil
d'administration qui n'en finissait plus
de grandes décisions à prendre et bien
entendu toutes les responsabilités qui
me retombe toujours sur le dos au jeu
devait de présenter tirer mon mari
monsieur raoult il gâcha absolument
ravie de faire votre connaissance
monsieur oui comme je te l'aï dit tout à
l'heure au téléphone monsieur gaschard
m'a rendu à très grands services
infiniment aimable à vous monsieur je
vais vous rembourser sur le champ ça ne
vous ennuie pas que je vous donne un
chèque bas cette année que je
préfèrerais du liquide pour une seule
petite somme
je n'ai jamais d'argent sur moi à vous
non plus comment faites vous lorsque
vous sortez tous les deux ensemble
je signe vous ayez un chèque et bien
alors cinéma à chaque fois nous ne
paraît pas si vous avez un stylo ah bah
oui monsieur j'ai aussi un stylo voilà
bien sûr avec un dé s'il vous plaît à
comme vous voudrez pas faire les bons
comptes font les bons amis mon stylo
bon eh bien je crois que je n'ai plus
qu'à me retire non mais pas avant
d'avoir couillard whisky géraldine tu
n'as pas offert un whisky à messieurs
gâcher si si si si madame la valette et
une hôtesse parfaite elle m'a offert un
bon alors quoi des aurès bon non non non
écoute tu vois bien que monsieur gâcher
à les presser et bien il faudra que nous
dînions semble assez soir je suis sûr
que nous avons des tas d'amis comme nous
avons déjà fait le tour de nos relations
et madame laval m moi je mettrais ma
main au feu que nous avons déjeuné
ensemble chez marie cas est ce que tu as
dit que non tu vieillis
alors hop c'est votre nom qui sonne
familier à mes oreilles voilà sans doute
et puis peut-être vous êtes-vous fait
installé récemment une salle de bain des
hommages présenter mais un hommage à
madame gaza ah mais vous le ferez vous
même un jour ou l'autre certainement
j'espère bientôt bientôt oui enfin les
conditions seront tels que je ne vous le
souhaite l'europe
et ce qui la fait pas l'air de lui
plaire je lui plais moi ça suffit o
comme gaffeur tu sais tu pose un peu là
haut j'ai pas été aimable mais si du
foie trotter toujours dix fois trop
aimable mais tu prennes l'air
indifférent d'accord mais ne joue pas
les maris complaisez 1 quand même quoi
le coût du chèque
j'ai pas trouvé que ça avait de la
gueule je trouvais ça idiot il essaie en
trois visions tu me prends pour un
amateur géraldine j'ai oublié de signer
c'est un bout de papier sans valeur
il s'en apercevoir j'ai oublié ça arrive
bon boulot tu viens ville aux bravos
j'ai une soudaine envie de cavia titre à
des nouilles puisqu'on est invité je
suis habité et moi mais jamais la
première fois tu le sais bien atterrir
c'est par le marchand clio email le
[ __ ] je leur en bourse il n'est même
pas la correction de m'habiter avec ma
femme
vidange mais qu'elle roule keller quelle
robe d'un rouge de celle de rosette met
au message de roses après les plus sexy
oui il faut peut-être en faire trop on
emmène le don à la carpe honneur j'ai
laissé une petite ardoise ils la font
passer dans l'addition comme d'habitude
j'y pense au cas où ils chercheraient
département oui tu me dira qu'il ya
toutes les chances pour qu'ils ne
cherchent pas d'appartement après tout
on ne sait jamais j'ai tout à fait ce
qui lui faut qu est en fleurs boiseries
18e 250 millions une pochette peuple
mais au bien entendu nous partagerons la
commission fifty fifty en quoi d'autre
dit qu'est ce qu'on pourrait bien lui
taz est évidemment il ya toujours la
boîte à mouches de la grande catherine
mais faut vraiment hâte amateurs et
c'est donc de la faire frire un oui tu
peux m'aider parce que je suis vraiment
un va au fond mais dit on and on ne s'en
prive pas de ça
mais dites donc de bien nerveuse et ya
de quoi je t'assure et pourquoi grand
dieu ce que je dois réussir réussir
allez vous et à l'épousé la wii en
d'immenses et ça va pas non comprend
moins bien on divorce mais ça ne change
rien entre nous et après naturellement
je te réponds après après la mort de son
mari
bah oui si elles tardent pas trop sinon
le ton est ferme à plottes deux ans
maximum et ans roulera sans l'or c'est
fou ma petite géraldine ce que tu peux
parler pour le regarder
oui je sais à première vue ça surprend
un peu mais en y réfléchissant je vais
rien du tout mais d'abord parce que je
n'ai aucune envie de devenir son amant
au c'est flatteur
je suis ton mari je le reste et puis je
trouve ta petite combinaison himal
thierry mort fait bon et mareuil regarde
à toi regarde moi nous sommes dit moreau
heureux d'être dans mon immoralité je
tiens à conserver les formes
je suis à l'immoral apprécié
guinchard est veuf il a besoin de
tendresse accueilli géraldine peut
pourtant pas dire que j'ai pas les idées
larges
j'ai même les hits est
exceptionnellement large bon si les
hommes sont assez bêtes pour l'inviter à
dîner d'affaires des fleurs un parfait
avoir un bijou et d'être payée de retour
que par intégration et sourire je ne
vois pas pourquoi nous nous profiterions
pas mais attention hein
des sourires c'est tout ce que je leur
accorde de toi cyril laisse moi serait
un monsieur kasha
ce sera un mariage blanc battu pense
lever marchera projet l'âge de sa fille
ce dont il a besoin avant tout ceux
d'une présence sa fière de montrer à son
bras de me sortir quand on rase tout
frais tout de suite comprendre qu'il ne
faut pas y songer
d'ailleurs il n'osera pas que tu dis il
m'a l'air très vert où elle est il quand
j'ai rencontré chez son médecin
alors tu vois mais enfin tu essaies
inconsciente parce que toute cette
histoire c'est très joli en théorie mais
sur le plan pratique
est-ce que tu as pensé ne vivrions plus
dans la même maison
nous dormirons plus dans le même lit tu
portes réunion qui portait sur
l'existence d'un autre témoin ashrel à
tout seul à t'attendre piano géraldine
non je préfère ne pas avoir d'argent
être carpes et me tout ça c'est une
question d'organisation
aux côtés de brac excuse moi je t'aime
je t'aime tu m'aimes que nous aimons
c'est une affaire entendue
ce qui l'est moins c'est la chaîne map
en terre gelée promise tapant terre tu
l'auras un jour en attendant je maigris
tu maigri prend des vitamines dont je ne
me sens plus indiquée en l'occurrence
car mon commentaire je maigris passe le
maigri je maigris m apostrophe je
deviens et puis roger parler du bon bah
calme toi mais toutes façons de série la
panthère
c'est un tout petit détail il est
question notre bonheur mon cher
oui voilà déjà il a des ailes c'est
plutôt bon signe un bond à toi tu
disparais assez charmant je ne savais
pas que j'étais si encombrant mouchotte
s'était si bien parti sur ton scénario
mais bon sinon on va travailler tu
penses comme j'ai la tête à mon
cedarview maintenant un à lille va vite
oui ah bah oui je connais le schéma
merci syrie sinon on croise pas qu'on me
donner un peu de courage
allons je t'en prie un peu de décence tu
entends ton mari voilà je n'ai pas été
trop long jusque là c'est pour nous
faire des girondins a piqué était obligé
de me rendre à un séminaire de la
robinetterie au home et comment s'est
faite belle
on a essayé pour vous au ballon et pour
qui d'autre
cette petite sortie je m'en fais une
vraie fait vous savez bien alors nous
allons tout faire pour que ça soit une
alors qu'audi dont nous mais j'ai réussi
à me libérer du dîner où j'étais invité
je pense la soirée avec vous la soirée
avec nous oui or à la dernière minute
c'était un peu cavalier mais ma foi tant
pis ah oui mais vos amis vont
certainement beaucoup vont regretter
pareille série c veut nous emmener à la
carpe de la carpe d'or il paraît que
c'est un vrai coup de fusil mais enfin
c'est donc avez vous l'intention
d'inviter ma femme mon cher dans un seul
service qui a perdu la raison
non j'ai pas dis nous c'est un moteur
vous avez votre voiture naturellement
rabat naturellement forme et bien
allons-y
voulez vous je vous dise monsieur je
vous trouve très sympathique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
saint-tropez pour coiffer qu'ils aillent
tous audience
[Musique]
regarde regarde ces départements je
connaissais pas la moitié de nos invités
et on voit d'oiseaux à une culotte
débarqué avec 5 pers
j'ai trouvé à l'équipe en train de
prendre une douche dans la salle de bain
non c'est pas vrai mais qu'est ce que tu
as fait et je vais penser un peignoir de
bain qu'est ce que tu voulais que je
fasse on y est et pourquoi pas le
fictionnel que mon eau de cologne
le flacon a disparu quoi celui d'annie
trappe et nantes amis et c'est pour ça
qu'il lui en prit ok le long but also va
donner un café un dessin de 5 sur le
miroir de ma coiffe avec montrouge halal
il dit d'ailleurs aidé il ya du noyau
des livres et surtout les coûts sont
pauvres et un v10 dont ils sont tous
partis ivre mort ça fait un cocktail
travailliste toujours chez nous à tous
et que j'essayais de refiler la rolls au
prince
sinon ces deux belles images il faut se
poser la question à l'image une fois que
c'était la sienne nous soyons tous les
deux de la même voiture
ses membres ainsi et tu ne sais pas le
plus beau quoi il a essayé de me taper
non c'est ma petite fille en gros c'est
vraiment eu la crise y est un gros bidon
c'est pas tout ça mais comment allons
nous les payer lasser ses boissons et
sandwichs bon joly ah oui les aides
s'accumulent dans le vertige les coupes
de bol d'air est quoi les poubelles
gervais les deux mains qui renaît forte
au flou
deux sont des trophées au poids de
l'argent ça va pas chercher très loin
baros toi quand même pour tirer au moins
100 francs ah bon sang froid pourquoi
100 francs pour faire un cadeau à raul
quoi j'ai même entendu bateau à monsieur
cash à adiaké longtemps qu'on avait pas
parlé de lui celui là c'est une autre
planche de salut tu le sais bien
alors je t'en prie nous couper les
cheveux en quatre tu lui as déjà faire
une de mes cravate la plus jolie
là les miss qu'une fois sur ses deux
mandats ça roule c'est pas marrant nous
couvrons de se cacher de cadeaux quant à
lui ne se décide pas vite on dirait à
t'offrir tapant terre de somalie il a la
grippe c'est pas la grippe qui
l'empêchent de signer un chèque mots il
n'observe il veut être sûr d'être aimé
pour lui même se doit le convaincre de
mon désintéressement alors tu pensais
pas grand monde des guinéens
bref tu me dépouille pourrait me gardais
et lui de son côté qu'est ce qu'il nous
donne
ne te préoccupe a dû ce qu'il me donne
tirer considère plutôt ce que je vais
lui prendre mais si tu dois le plus mais
fait vite en tout cas parce qu'ils
n'obtiendront que le coût très longtemps
bonjour je n'aurais pas dû de moraliste
comme ça tu es fatigué très fatigué mais
revient bien faire dodo quoi on se
couche déjà
bah oui qu'est ce que tu veux faire
d'autre on va moi tu sais je suis jamais
contre elle est bien là ce tout ça je
mangerai en rentrant parce que tu sors
je suis même déjà très en retard monstre
de dieu ne me dis pas plus et rendez
vous ce soir avec raul presque tous les
soirs maintenant je finis par me
demander si tu t'ennuies longtemps avec
lui que prétend
bon allez vous d'abord salle gaveau avec
monsieur gâcha était grippé des lainages
abx a tout pour plaire tel casanova dit
donc c'est pour ça que tu m'as envoyé à
me coucher
là c'est plus sain que traîner dans les
boîtes j'essaie de tromper la solitude
c'est tout ben moi quand je servais
grand'rue je suis toujours en train vers
minuit rassure toi ma chère ce soir je
dirais pas traîner dans les boîtes
rester bien sagement à la maison prend
l'aspect les noyaux de lits des
passerelles aspirateur tirer cette
fatigue pas trop même si tu dors tu te
réveilles ray
même si je ne dors pas je fais semblant
pas durer comme ça alors je prenne les
décisions sérieuses
[Applaudissements]
chez moi madame vous monsieur thierry
laval est madame je ne vous connais pas
mais moi non plus vous êtes sans doute
une amie de mme loiseau un oiseau n
ferriol madame sonfonia venez vous
asseoir la reprenez vos esprits
pendant ce temps là je vais chercher un
verre d'eau avec une pincée de
bicarbonate d'abord monsieur voulez vous
m'expliquer voilà comment je me trouve
ici rassurez-vous vous n'avez pas été
kidnappé enfin récapitule dont je me
revois très bien à 7 heures au bar du
riz dans un bar déjà j'ai commandé un
article et puis un deuxième fait comment
le savez-vous je ne vois jamais une
intuition
je m'ennuyais j'étais seul je suis mis
alors évidemment comment résister au
troisième martini ce sont les italiens
de la table à côté qui monte à faire des
gens charmants reeves et leurs noms dans
mon sac
ils ont insisté pour me viennent me voir
à milan après longtemps mais derrière le
panthéon j'étais ami avec qui pendait
l'axé manière les jours
[Musique]
le punch et est exquis entre parenthèses
après les martinis j'ai continué avec du
champagne c'est l'horreur dames
tout ce qu'on attend c'est à ce
vernissage quel bien dit ça je tenais un
vernis
je ne sais plus où lui exposer des trucs
en fil de fer
j'avais perdu une excuse doit reprendre
tout se brouille un peu normal oui et
tout ça se termine dans la niche du
bouddha vous vous sentez mieux je crois
parfait il ya une station de taxis au
coin de l'avenue très bien monsieur
merci c'est la première fois qu'une
chose pareille vous avez fait moins de
dégâts que les autres j'espère monsieur
que vous n'aurez pas une trop mauvaise
opinion du bas vous auriez pu me casser
le nez est un véritable danger public
en effet et dans le zoo si je vous
disais monsieur que j'hésite pas à faire
l'effort de porter une cigarette un bel
arbre pour l'allumer je laisse le gard
mais il est vraiment pas pratique
une pierre admirable et star il fait de
l'effet vendetta comment il est faux
tout ce qu'il faut c'est dommage
d'ailleurs mes bracelets aussi haut
je pense que des bijoux faut comme ce
trou quoi puisque ce sont les copies des
vrais que je garde encore à bon port
c'est bien monsieur que je n'aurai pas
la bêtise de porter à vos doigts un
caillou de 300 millions
une femme seule comme moi une femme
seule au oui évidemment eh bien je crois
que
nous vous avons assez encombré mondiale
en émoi pour la deuxième fois monsieur
au revoir et encore toutes nos excuses
non je ne vous laisserai pas partir
comme ça comment voulez vous que je pars
vous êtes à peine remise de votre le
tour du sport même pas faire venir une
ans du nom de la loge et vous un petit
mot mort il est 13 e vous savez le temps
je ne me sens pas tout à fait dans mon
assiette rester autant que vous voudrez
je ne vous donnerai pas de monde
vous n'aviez pas vont être accomplies je
ne vous suis pas trop antipathique
j'ai envie de rentrer à l'inter je
souffrais sommes vraiment quelle joie
voit bien que vous en avez pas de quoi
ça me comprenez moi je veux dire c'est
un vrai plaisir de vous garder ici
encore quelques instants notamment
monsieur c'est fou ce que vous êtes
mais il serait peut-être temps que je me
présente madame annie par koba espagnols
ou sud américaine colombienne quand mon
mari j'habite bogota mais je suis né à
paris vos coeurs et rester ainsi vous
voyager seules
whissell presse avec ma femme de chambre
secrétaire
mon chauffeur et mes deux caniches nains
ce n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
monsieur votre mari est toujours la ba
112 et ça m'étonnerait fort qu'il
embauche jacques qu'il en boucle il
n'aime pas les voyages on lui a pas
demandé son avis il est couché bien sale
dont le beau mausolée tout neuf que je
lui ai fait construire vous êtes donc
veuve
en un sens c'est triste évidemment mais
je peux vous l'avouer en confidence
n'était pas un mariage d'amour 30 ans de
plus que moi et le petit indien très
prononcé vraiment seulement il y avait
plein le platine
oui ces mines de platine c'est à dire
maintenant ma mine de platine aux
battues vous a laissé ses mines de
platine ce gentil
émergent ne voudriez pas que je me sois
tu as fait 20 ans du côlon vie est un
art qui tenait plus petit plus du
chimpanzé que de l'homme pour des prunes
c'est un point de vue très défendable
que le vôtre madame mais j'ai été très
honnête remarqué quand ils m'ont enlevé
au music-hall oui j'avais débuté à
l'européen dans le tour sont aujourd'hui
dit ali ba je cherche l'amour et toi tu
m'apportes que l'argent faut prendre ce
qu'on trouve c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai
épousé j'ai sacrifié ma carrière et je
les rends dit très heureux mais de là à
dire que c'était tous les jours une
folle rigolade alors la paix sociale
vous voilà libres comme l'air toujours
jeune jaime défend et riche
c'est ce que je me répète plus encore
que vous l'imaginez le vieux tabou bah
oui je me le dis mais ce n'est plus tout
à fait ça - du vin gollum je me faisais
une fed ce retour à paris pendant des
années il en ai rêvé total
j'échoue lamentablement derrière votre
barre mais vous êtes sur mon canapé
maintenant tout ça ne serait pas arrivé
si je ne me sentais pas seul à monsieur
24 heures à tuer c'est long surtout
quand les magasins sont fermés
allons allons allons allons un peu de
courage je me demande en face il n'est
pas trop tard pour commencer de
nouvelles pas il n'est jamais trop tard
enfin je veux dire vous tombez juste au
bon moment
c'est idiot que vous dites là haut parce
que tant qu'à choisir si ça n'avait
perdu que deux mois j'aurais choisi
plutôt où est il le temps où je
déjeunais d'un café près
du côté de la porte saint-martin à
oreillettes scories hier avec les
copains au fond voyez-vous l'amour pour
la voir pour comprendre que l'on peut
très bien s'en passer
alors oui mais pour le comprendre il
faut d'abord la voilà donc il ne me
reste plus qu'une solution saine
m'arranger avec et d'en tirer le maximum
mais vous verrez qu'on y arrive très
bien bien sûr il ya des compensations
mais l'essentiel croyez moi je suis
passé à côté mais qu'est ce que c'est
pour vous l'essentiel cette question
c'est l'amour comme hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop mes bijoux mécaniques mais
tout ça ne me suffit pas tenez jean va
parfois j'en viens parfois a regretté
hannibal mais excusez moi monsieur de me
laisser aller
ainsi devant vous je ne sais pas ce qui
m'arrive je me sens toute chose
ce changement de climat à paris pour se
distraire n'y a que l'embarras du choix
vous verrez et ne serait-ce que de
flâner dans les rues au hasard des
marronniers sont en fleurs tu peux pas
marcher j'ai l'échiquier nous irons en
voiture couverte
nous venons à peine de faire
connaissance justement nous nous
arrêtons pas en si bon chemin
vous devez être occupés non je me
débrouillerai j'ai peur de déranger au
prévenu passe là-bas dame au contraire
je vois envoûtant de ressources nous
nous plus madame corps et moi thierry
alors par quoi commencer temps et bien
que diriez vous pour commencer un dîner
en musique sur le bateau mouche la place
des vosges au clair de lune
c'est parti ensuite vous voudrez
peut-être rentrer vous coucher un nom à
jamais avec mes à samedi à caen je
propose les allemands mais manger des
gaufres au luxembourg oui si vous êtes
sages et foire du trône si on les
chevaux de bois
quel programme nous errons marché aux
fleurs au musée grévin au marché aux
puces
connaissez-vous le grand trianon si je
connais le grand trianon vas tu parles
j'ai habité pendant vingt et un
personnes non non à bogota hannibal
avait fait reconstruire pour moi avec
ses colonnes rose et son jet d'eau en
plus grand parce que
n'empêche que le grand trianon gens mais
bon alors pas de trianon mais la tour
eiffel vous n'aviez pas la tour eiffel
ou moins dans votre jardin
j'aurais et bien leur pas d'objection
pour la tour eiffel à faudra absolument
que je vous emmène faire les antiquaires
nous marchanderont par ci par là
quelques babioles haut à propos si vous
vous intéressez aux objets anciens
je vous signale que j'ai une récemment
entre les mains la boîte à mouches de la
grande catherine una beauté et ail blanc
serti d'or avec une grosse émeraude
gravés aux armes de lazzari vous l'avez
mois encore
bah il faudrait que je vous emmène dîner
dans un petit restaurant très rigolo
comment s'appelle-t-il la carpe d'or il
ya des années que j'en ai envie
justement ce fait leur spécialité et moi
j'ai pas peur de la à bon enfin j'en
prendrai aussi un petit mois je crois
que me valent à paris pour pour
longtemps dans ce cas pourquoi ne pas
chercher tout de suite un appartement
par ex et à tout va j'en ai un qui vous
tend les bras canon flamboyer 18e jeunes
francs il est à vous mais c'est
merveilleux vous savez que vous
connaissez tous une petite fille
j'aime à rendre service mon appartement
vous m'aiderez à l'installer compter sur
moi je pourrais tout non
et ça sera charmant et moi j'ai été très
très très très intelligente de portes
après prendre un premier martini au bar
du risque ces gentils chez vous c'est ok
vous aimez n'est pas encore tout à fait
installer il doit en passer des femmes
dans sa garçonnière au laventure facile
de mettre encore ça ne vous serait
pourtant pas difficile avec une gentille
petite gueule d'amour comme la pauvre
cora nous allons le rater raté quoi le
bateau mouche
nous prendrons le suivant j'ai fait moi
bah vous on est bien ici mais j'ai des
fourmis dans les jambes
vous avez une cuisine oui pourquoi c'est
par là si vous voulez faire non réfugiés
david vient de nous mais plus c'est une
cuisine comme toutes les cuisines n'est
jamais une cuisine thierry de règles
j'étais trop pau où j'étais trop riche
2-2 mon réchaud à alcool de ma jeunesse
je suis passé à mon chef
médaillé de bronze et hakim interdit dès
l'entrée des cantines c'est la vie j'en
ai bavé
vous êtes une en soirée et venez venez
nous allons faire la cuisine ailleurs sa
santé j'ai trouvé à paris ni des
bulgares et que c'est la catastrophe
vous aimez les sorties gars qu'est ce
que c'est vous allez voir vous allez
vous régaler allons bon
thierry goor tenait en diamant quoi pour
moi mais les faux pas c'est bien pour ça
que tu avais je vous le prête le temps
de pétrir les tortillas
violents vagues et toi aussi les noms
raul
je peux tu dire c'était plus fort que
moi il a fallu absolument que je vienne
de monter date annoncée la nouvelle
nouvelle
à l'arrivée tout raconter ces temps-ci
important tu as toi bien tes les
premières mesures du second mouvement du
poids thouars de mendelson j'ai senti
qu'il allait se passer quelque chose
raul était très agité noël rouge oui et
coûteux la santé de monsieur k sharma
diffère complètement à côté pendant la
taxe you
le voilà tout le problème en public ces
bonbons ou d'insérer un briquet les
doigts et au beau milieu d'une carte sim
au temps du match sans doute sous
l'effet combiné de la musique et des
sulfamides il se penche à mon oreille ça
pour me connaissent et me transitoire et
me soutient d'une voix tremblante
géraldine je ne peux plus vivre sans mes
coups de je ne passerais volontiers de
tous ces détails mois se sautent sur
l'occasion et j'ai lu on voit qu'à cela
ne tienne rôle je divorce et père jadis
a dit à total presque sans réfléchir je
trouve au contraire que tu fais preuve
de beaucoup de suite dans les idées
j'ai cru que raul aller en avant une
attaque et sa suite étaient un peu tôt
il répète le jura d'une mais géraldine
tous les gens autour de nous faisait
sud-sud j'étais henry blement gêné je
vais entraîner un quart d'heure avant la
fin du concert
voilà félicitations oui je les ferme à
dans la voiture du temps me souffler
sous le prétexte monté lui chercher des
gouttes pour le nez dans rue mais
thierry qu'est ce qu'on décide
qu'est ce qu'on décide n'as-tu pas déjà
tout décidé mais bon ça avant mais
prochaine éthique paroles en l'air
maintenant ils deviennent réalisa oui tu
es très fort pas tant que ça tirait chez
apple merci à tout le monde avant de
plonger dans un moment pareil je devrais
te sentir et mes côtés pour te pousser
voici le faux nom géraldine ne compte
pas son droit regarde-moi thierry tu
sais très bien que je ne peux pas refusé
d'épouser raul c'est pour mieux nous la
seule celui
la seule oui peut-être pas justement
quels autres qu'elles ont eu d'écouté
monsieur gaschard est en train d'être un
peu une pneumonie
1 alors ne le fait pas attendre plus
longtemps qu'est ce que je vois là
qu'est ce que tu vois on a dit à manger
alors tu as folk pas c'est du toc hdidou
je raconterai sweat et thierry j'ai peur
de qui de quoi
on s'est un moment d'égarement tu
n'aurais pas commis d'imprudence de
prudence
ah oui visiter l'appartement du dessous
par exemple pourquoi je rêve du tda
romanesque ah je vois tu a engagé une
femme de ménage elle a retiré ses bijoux
pour faire la vaisselle
c'est vraiment pas le moment je
t'expliquerai tous plus tard bien cette
poule dans la twizy ce n'est pas une
poule
alors qu'est ce qu'elle fait dans ma
cuisine je n'ai pas dit le bol des
tortues car soir je te jure que ce la
vérité que te reçoivent un fan sous le
toit conjugal alors que tâches entre 12
et de gambie au contraire je trouve ça
n'est pas twilight quoi attendre parce
que tu une cache il s'agit d'une affaire
tient madame hannibal escobar est une
dame richissimes américains d'où
sort-elle nom de la niche du bouddha
pourquoi pas la cheminée où il écoute je
t'assure tout ça pas extravagant mais il
faut que tu me fasses confiance ville
et si je te disais quand deux minutes
j'ai réussi à me caser la boîte à
mouches de la grande catherine sembla
sans blague
quitte à tomber pas à celle-là c'est une
folle non on n'est pas folle elle a le
goût du beau et j'essaie de m'inspirer
de la sympathie et de la confiance c'est
bien ce que je dirais femme écoute si je
parviens à la distraire et à satisfaire
ses caprices satisfait assez cartoon pas
m'interrompre notre avenir est assuré
nous allons ou faire commanditer par
madame escobar commandité 10 10 le sucre
ou mettez vous le 6 au bon morceau voilà
le premier se trouve tout en haut du
placard au four à gauche et le deuxième
dans une boîte sur lequel il est écrit
poire merci madame
c'est ça madame animal magique c'est ça
comme tu dis mais je te dispense de ses
appréciations bienveillante aux jeunes
et à tous pas si mal elles vont bien un
muscle gâcha oui bon qu'est ce qu'on va
lui faire acheter maintenant comment
comment ah oui après la boîte à mouche
parce que tout la prétention de
t'occuper avec moi de madame escobar
c'est moi été découverts cora c'est moi
seul qui traiteraient avec elle cora
s'il appelle déjà corps un lapin propos
qu'est ce que vous attendez pour nous
présenter
j'allais le faire vous étiez déjà partie
excusez moi mon mari aussi distrait ch
votre mari oui vous n'avez pas dit que
vous étiez là je voulais pas dit tu
penses que c'est lui parce que j'étais
obligé alors détails sans importance
tout ça n'est ce pas vous avez géraldine
ne se formalise pas pour si peu
d'ailleurs elle était sur le point de
sortir
mais ce n'est pas à cause des le voyeur
j'ai l'habitude madame vous savez nous
avons beaucoup d'amis notre porte est
toujours grande ouverte
on va ou bien vous en savez quelque
chose savez ici chacun s'agite à sa
façon espace géraldine oui enfin toi
surtout mon chéri didon j'y croyais que
ton chevaliers servants attendait en bas
dans sa voiture ne peut pas refaire ce
que tu fais tu ferais tu fais de raul
tout d'un coup laisser tranquille
madame j'aurais aimé faire plus ample
connaissance et une autre fois valable
une autre fois vous voyez comme il aime
anna d'un exclusif moi même je n'ai pas
le droit de partager ses amis on se
demande vraiment pourquoi vous avez
besoin de tant d'amis un jeune couple si
sympathique tout d'un coup moi même j'ai
l'impression que je suis tout à part toi
comment pouvez vous dire une chose
pareille
lyon c'est moi de m'excuser de troupes
bien un tant soit peu votre charme en
tête à tête
cela ne me regarde pas mais j'ai
l'impression que tous les deux vous êtes
en train de faire des bêtises
c'est de notre âge madame ne croyez pas
cela il n'y a pas d'âge et la sq ont
l'habitude on va vous le tube l'ira ou
la non mais laisse tranquille tu me
tiens toujours de raul
pourquoi me demandez vous pas à ce
monsieur de monter il ya sept tortillas
aux quatre anneaux non encore annoncés
moi pas que ce soit une bonne idée non
oui c'est vrai c'est une sympathique pas
beaucoup je n'ai rien dit mais moi je
vous préviens je suis décidé à passer
une excellente soirée
j'espère que vous allez nous sortir une
patte tellement cher vous avez encore
soit je crois qu'un peu de votre cave
normes entrées de la vodka après les
martinis le punch le champagne est bien
tiré
qu'attends tu pour courir chercher on
restera si les magasins sont fermés
si l'italien ils sont ouverts jusqu'à
minuit tu sais bien oui géraldine oui
giral bing encore à vous en avez
vraiment très envie je me suis donné la
peine de faire des tortillas je trouve
que la moindre des choses serait que
vous alliez chercher à moi absolument
madame foule se coince dans ce cas
puisque vous vouliez toutes les deux
contre un bras tu t'en vaudrait satwa
trop large dans mon sac
il n'a jamais un sou 10 dont géraldine
je te préviens marie qu'est-ce-qui un
trou donc tu m'a très bien compris oui
je vais je couvre gpara s'il le faut
géraldine je mange
[Applaudissements]
votre charmant votre mari aussi
d'ailleurs je trouve tous les deux
charmants c'est entièrement réciproque
alors pourquoi ne serions nous pas de
bonnes à nous employons nous y employons
nous y au nom de notre amitié naissante
et aussi parce que je suis un âne
tu peux plus vieux que vous je me
permets tout de suite de vous mettre en
garde contre quoi il ya une chose que
les hommes ne supporte pas c'est qu'on
les humilie en présence d'une autre
femme je ne vous suis pas vous venez de
dire à votre mari de prendre de l'argent
dans votre sac de vendre vous avais tu
as ces délicatesses sont d'une autre
époque où madame et non plus court entre
jeunes ménages de notre génération la
mienne ne remonte tout de même pas à
vercingétorix
d'ailleurs je les trouve bien fragile
les jeunes ménages de votre génération
vraiment rompu une finale qu'on parle
lui d'une seule pièce il faut que je
dise des choses telles qu'elles sont
dites il ya bien un monsieur qui vous
attend en bas denses a battu par segment
et alors alors pendant ce temps là notre
mari lui son côté reçoit dans votre
appartement c'est avoir sonné
une dame
oui
je ne comprends pas très bien votre
agressivité madame vous êtes une dame
très respectable pourtant ah oui ça je
vous remercie
j'ai mis à 72 venir je ne vois pas très
bien cette conversation nous mêmes à
cette conclusion qui reste son mari tout
seul de fort risque de le perdre soyez
rassurés thiery est fou de moi j'avais
de la chance
c'est un garçon très séduisant oh oui je
trouve aussi c'est même un peu pour ça
que je l'épousé je ne voudrais pas me
mêler de ce qui ne me regarde pas
continue exemple mais je vous assure
qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes qui volent à
la vraie volontiers qu'elle essaye ne
les encourage et pas elle risque est
vous prendre mots que voulez-vous savoir
au juste sur mon mari madame s'il fait
bien à vous le fur est il mal avec vous
mon petit que cela ne voudrais vraiment
ghadir il est vrai que vous avez eu le
temps d'acquérir une riche expérience
oui je sais vous avez 25 ans et j'en ai
un peu plus
n'empêche que je peux encore plaire aux
murs suis convaincu vous aurez toutes
sortes ta très haut débit oublier
thierry ça vaudra mieux pour vous vous
perdriez votre temps et votre argent
rejet l'aider à ne savoir qu'en faire il
joue vous savez à quoi à tout comme un
forcené poker bakar hadji nous l'appui
il faudra je lui demande de la compagnie
hong de préférence à ce moment il n'aura
pas pu parce qu'il doit au oui et quand
ils voient ils cassent tout vous bâti
par révéler c'est comme c'est excitant
par les vois encore devenu paresseux
invétéré une fiche rien rien rien tant
que les hommes qui travaillent trop
nessel ne sont jamais libre pour ses
passes en cash de la firme coureurs
comme pas un c'est que les autres à ses
yeux ont plus d'attrait que vous ma
petite chatte gens qui le fait qu'une
femme comme vous avec ce monstre parce
que c'est un monstre que vous venez de
décrire
n'exagérons rien et puis moi j'ai la
défense ou en aidant non thierry n'est
pas un garçon digne de vous aussi moi je
vais vous rendra service à service je
vous en débarrasser
non mais vous en débarrasser je vous le
prend mais qu'est ce que vous dites il
juste assez pour on aime une femme pour
son grain de beauté ses fossettes son
petit pied pourquoi pas pensant d'argent
question
je l'étais à ne savoir qu'en faire et
j'ai cru comprendre que kerry avait un
faible pour l'argent il ya toutes les
chances pour qu'ils m'adorent le bonheur
ça m'a l'air de très bien collé entre
footeux de quoi parier vous ne vous mon
cher à votre pharmacie vous dépeindre ou
de telle couleur que je suis conquise
définitivement elle a dû me flatte et
non pas exactement
géraldine peut-être très gentil quand
elle veut ah non bon eh bien c'est dans
l'euphorie générale que nous allons
lever nos verres de vodka
quelques noms célèbres juste sait-on
jamais thierry et il vous livre demain
matin où j'ai bien quelques rendez-vous
mais pourquoi je voudrais visité au plus
vite cet appartement du quai aux fleurs
aux jeunes plus facile et puis ensuite
il vous le voulez bien nous passerons
chez cartier chez cartier j'ai décidé de
vous offrir un cadeau je crois beaucoup
à la vertu des cadeaux en amitié au
géraldine aussi aux kora non vraiment je
ne sais pas si il faudra bien vous m'y
habituer j'essaierai appel à toi de miss
positions changent de couleur et elle
tombe d'inanition sûrement on va lui
donner à manger tu auras vous êtes une
femme merveilleuse et vous d'une d'une
croisière aux canaries pour canaris
l'excellente idée
eh ben vous voyez nous voguerons sens
vers les cannas tarek les voyages
forment la jeunesse
tout m'a l'air de marcher comme sur des
roues la salle est meilleur oui elle me
semble dans les meilleures dispositions
non dit géraldine tu te rends compte
très bien oui c'est le père noël qui
nous tombe du ciel après mois de juin
johnny et non pas dans mon lit dans
l'élite du foot français eric faye
naissant tu sais très bien ce que ton
père noël adam a tâté du moment qu'elle
achète l appartement du quai aux fleurs
et la bastide c'est toi quel poste et
moi les maladies a plaisanté en papier
tous deux pris du poids mais jusque là
elle s'est très bien tenu parole
d'honneur thierry je te demande de
couper court et tout de suite et
l'appartement et la boîte à mouches mais
vrai il en valait la peine
oh et puis je sais ce que j'ai à faire
thiery il est temps que je prenne mes
responsabilités je suis l'homme le chef
de famille à moi de subvenir à ses
besoins en faisant quoi exactement
mon devoir c'est à dire je me sacrifie
d'abord des kids on roule
thomassin évident fatma encore à suffira
amplement à équilibrer notre budget si
tu crois oui pas entendu platine et
d'étudiants mois et s'était tu vas faire
longtemps pris en jetant pression se
fait arrêter par les mots eh bien je
vais te le dire quand même le gigolo et
de mauvais esprit tu peux avoir un
gigolo géraldine retire ce que tu
viennes des tarifs débutant salut
scandale que touchera nous y sommes dans
le scandale ici ce concours a commencé
une dernière fois si tu ne fais pas
sortir ces dernières lui même
la cuisine c'est moi qui m'en irai à
laisser ça va te retrouves est allé se
cacher ben ouais c'est bien mais pour
l'instant tous les deux
m
vite vous n'aviez pourtant pas l'air
s'est passé voilà vingt minutes que
j'attends dans la voiture
à vos souhaits merci d'y rester une
minute de plus dans cette maison la
porte grande ouverte oui c'est elle qui
fait les courants d'air je la ferme
permettez-moi ans david s mais qu
avez-vous géré à vis de vous n'êtes pas
un état d'agitation extrême de temps
premier d'affaires et je suis à vous
tout de suite
prenez vos affaires vous êtes à moi oh
mais c'est un véritable écran n'est pas
oubliée l'échelle de soie
non mais voyons gérald et vous savez
très bien que j'ai déjà commis une
imprudence ce soir en allant qu'on fait
et on nous sommes plus à une solide
preuve
alors oui mais j'irai me suggéra keynes
était de coeur l'emportent toujours par
une enfant géraldine en quittant le
domicile conjugal vont mettre dans votre
temps cette fois c'est bref y ait
d'autres tarn contre lui et puis vous
n'allez par côté pendant des heures
j'espère bien au moral et les liens du
mariage le sol dubaï ne se dénoue pas
aussi légèrement tout de même je croyais
voulait plus vivre sans moi vous la
voulez oui ou non
ben c'est à dire que je te veux oui pas
bien sûr mais aussi la présence de
monsieur la rappeuse est terriblement
compliqué donc pas les choses m'ont viré
pts et 6 à fait dans la bonne humeur a
donc déjà ne croyez vous pas qu'il
serait plus un jeu tout remettre à
demain dans il n'a pas l'air chaud je
dirais quand tu avoueras houle ce soit
en manque et que c'est un peu à cause de
vous si je suis sur le point de quitter
mon foyer mais je suis très sensible m
vous tenu de le quitter en pleine nuit
enfin moi je le ferai je devrais déjà
être au lit à proposer goult laseris
trop vous demander que de le déposer
chez ma mère est non bien sûr gérad il
vous est vrai bien je suis à vos envies
j'espère qu'ils habitent par la banlieue
va enfin est l'amiral sa fille tatum sur
les bras ma cravate gris staccato vous
vous doutez pas qui peut les voir
c'est géraldine on est prêts monsieur je
vous en prie je vous assure que j'ai
tout fait pour éviter cette
confrontation
enfin gardons notre calme d'une manière
générale je suis ennemis du désordre et
de la précipitation
quant à la précipitation monsieur sans
vouloir vous vexer je crois que si vous
devez faire votre vie très bon tout de
même sans se précipiter de ne pas perdre
votre temps
ouais alors écoutez jeune homme soyez
comme aux joueurs parce qu'en
l'occurrence c'est vous qui tenait le
rôle du barbon alors fait le nom avec
cette bonne humeur que vous produits
étant tout à l'heure son père est
quelqu'un contraints de les affronter
au revoir monsieur au revoir monsieur
acte avant soirée merci a bientot
thierry
où est passée l'adorable géraldine elle
est partie quelle bonne idée
enfin nous voilà tous les ans je n'ose
encore il croit même suffire à ratier
thierry gaignon enivrons haut comme
j'aimerais être amoureux
pas au nom ne répondait pas il vaut
mieux parfois laisser toutes ces choses
dans le bar j'ai envie de riz de danse
et de mes tours dire je me sens prêt et
à toutes les folies
alors qu'ils rient quelconque faire le
ménage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ben ali a à cesser vous fera oui non non
non pas du tout non non mais alors là je
suis réveillé depuis longtemps 1 quelle
heure est il
au 11ème or à quoi c'est un grand jour
ah oui public aura oui c'est un grand
jour oui oui c'est un très grand joueur
koras ici si c'est le plus beau jour de
ma vie allait oui c'est ça oui oui je
passe vous prendre 8 pour aller à la
mairie c'est voilà tout de suite a tout
de suite
ouf
[Musique]
alors oui oui cora non qu aura
naturellement encore à l'essai si je
suis prêt presque oui non si vous qu'il
ne sait pas si vous continuez à me
téléphoner toutes les cinq minutes
oui comme base qu'est ce que j'ai oublié
or pardon je serai pas réparé monde là
encore les gars
jamais deux sans trois nous tirer du
calme
oui cora
je ne te dérange pas aussi on ne peut
pas tomber plus mal
tant mieux je suis très pressé on a que
moi je t'assure moins que moi je me
dépêche
mais dis moi il me semble que le
l'appartement s'est singulièrement vidée
depuis mon départ et deux trois petites
choses qui m'entouraient il est vrai que
je n'y ai pas mis les pieds depuis près
de six mois déjà
oui déjà rohff moi aussi le temps m'a
paru très court c'est la première fois
que nous renvoyons depuis notre divorce
amusant non c'est pour m'affronter que
tu viens le travail à la main j'ai fait
du cheval au bois tous les matins au
monsieur gaschard galope à tes côtés
il travaille lui à madame est ce que va
recevoir ses biens fabien je te remercie
alors il paraît que le grand événement
est imminent dans une demi-heure avant
en effet mais tu vois j'ai vraiment pas
le temps de te recevoir mes démos et si
ça passe avant c'est pourquoi acheter
une voiture
asus ne propose pas un patois si elle
est commandée à quand même s'il a
décroché ce n'est qu'un début
mais quoi je ne vois rien briller et et
doit pas le moindre con au mondial femme
se serait de bon goût mais quand tu vas
chez maxim's à givet encore les manu or
mon pauvre petit chou blanc mais je me
rate a un prix il fait comme chez toi
alors eh bien les mois ont passé
très vite ils ont passé quand même et on
pousse d'hergé va débarquer cecafa teint
parfait à la fin de la semaine la une de
ces vers l'est sera peut-être face on
avait quand il s'apercevra que son
nobili agissements
or il adore le camping alors de
frigidaires n'est plus là je réussi à
sortir de nuit sera pour moi qu'une
bagatelle
je te remets pas d'appartement d'hervé
dans l'état mais les faits n'ont les
installer l'air conditionné pour le
remercier
on verra dit donc si c'est pour faire
l'inventaire que tu es venu t'aurais pu
choisir un autre jour un ce que c'est
bien de savoir un petit mariage j'avais
une annonce dans le figaro
elle m'a pas sauté aux yeux je demande
pardon d'ailleurs je ne lis que les
faits divers aussi le délai crash
bientôt de tous les détails concernant
ton assassinat
mon essai 6 nov oui avec ce genre
d'équipé c'est toujours comme ça que ça
se termine
corey la douceur et la docilité même
acheter sur femmes cherchent de toi
chérie tu ne roule jamais ces plantes tu
veux les faire prendre la barre en
battant et pousser comme des toiles elle
éclate et de celle menant au regard de
la baisse le nez lamentablement travail
parce que j'ai fourré d'acrobates y
avait aussi sur ses tables à saint
brieuc voilée à des drops
qu'est devenu ce cendrier je lui ai
envoyé hayden rock and roll et voilà
bonjour c'est maintenant voyons bien
d'avoir deux de la même couleur de 0,6
en données mais tu vois pas ce qu'un fou
au milieu de ses chaussettes non ou
encore tu sois là investi côté il serait
temps qu'elle te paye à un ballet de
shantha dulcinée 1 depuis que je ne suis
plus là pour m'occuper des affaires
quelle différence oui ou non tu vas la
boucler j'ai besoin de me concentrer
ce qu'on a eu lieu
oui mon travail
a subi ce but comme manchette chaussures
au numéro cloud et des trésors pointu
plié en deux qu'est ce que tu fais
chanteur ici qu'est ce que tu attends
c'est pas uniquement d'inventaire un mot
de plus et je te dit bon je ne dis plus
rien et tu as we may chaussures tu la
tiens à main balou quoi est ce que je
sais moi je me vois l'instant les
prenant dans le placard tu ne sais même
plus ce que tu fais enfin cette
chaussure sa part en valais que même qui
s'est passé vraiment la journée des
catastrophes à ses jetons pris un objet
de faire d'esprit qui pourrait m'aider à
aller chercher ce que je veux dire que
tu penses tu avoir mal à cacher sucre à
ce conflit ne joue pas avec bennett a
demandé moi-même je te dirai ça va finir
par amalur ça va finir par un malheur et
bien un grand malin tu es souci c'est
les yeux c'est pas la fenêtre j'ai raté
deux sétois fait pas de bruit c'est
sûrement une facture à nuit si avec ce
nouveau papa tu vas voir voilà mr barry
on va lire
géraldine qu'est ce que vous faites ici
je me croyais parti faire du cheval
oui j'allais faire du cheval de sport
que vous cherchez une est pas là
j'arrive et je ne plaisante pas que
signifie votre présence ici
rien absolument rien par contre la route
ne me paraît pas très normal vous ne
suivez vous espionner mais non vous
savez très bien je suis venu chez mon
médecin qui habitent sur soi même palier
et qu'est ce que je vois au coin de la
rue ma voiture alors juger mon
étonnement
vous empruntez ma voiture pour aller à
votre manège et je la retrouve devant le
domicile de votre ex mari
bah oui barbus et c'est en passant par
hasard devant le domicile de mon ex mari
que j'ai décidé de monter un quidam en
terre oui enfin admettons
qu'est ce que c'est que cette chose si
c'est une preuve à conviction j'ai payé
la recevoir sur la tête alors épouse de
semaine comme un boeuf mais ça ne se
passera pas comme ça je vais faire faire
une enquête et je pensais tu es là tu
tournes d'avion renvoyons leurs pâtes
fraîches ont su comment travaille-t-on
chance lui en fait monsieur et j'y tiens
beaucoup
savez-vous monsieur je croyais vous
faire traduit en grec semaine monsieur
traduisez mois en tout ce que vous
voudrez mais laissez-moi m'habiller
tranquille
laissons tomber raul reste on dit je ne
comprends pas géraldine que vous ayez
encore des rapports directs avec ce
monsieur sans passer par l'intermédiaire
de votre avocat
vous avez raison raul comme d'habitude
et puis enfin vous êtes distraite vous
avez encore peur et ma voiture du côté
de la première quinzaine jeu les gars
est là où il y avait une classe
bah oui devant une porte cochère comme
nous sommes la deuxième quinzaine ça
fait des contraventions
enfin pensez y rappelle mon enfant
envoyons excusez moi mais j'avais voix
enterre les morts avoue oui ça je n'en
disconviens pas mais enfin la prochaine
fois pensez un peu pour l'avoir tant par
travailleur dit dans ça vous dérange
mais d'aller rouler ailleurs
dépêchons-nous j'ai manqué mon rendez
vous on se retrouve à donner votre jet
insiste pour que vous ne restez pas ici
plus longtemps et vous calmez vous je
dois être à deux heures précises c'est
mon avocat conseil
moi je croyais qu'on allait pouvoir et
vous croyez ça tous les jours
ben et froid proches mais ils sont pas
encore là mais il dit monsieur je vous
prie pas vous mêler à cette conversation
même si je vous ai déjà demandé la
poursuivre en dehors géraldine à propos
tenez vous prêt pour partir demain matin
pour sarreguemines demain matin pour
passer le week-end on libère quoi oui ma
présence là bas est indispensable déjà
perdu trop de temps à paris bercy ne
savais pas je pense puisque
en maine et puis autant éviter tous les
points de friction avec ma fille - vous
verrez lieu salle au bras mois de
novembre à sarreguemines ça doit être un
véritable enchantement
d'autant que nous n'aurons pas le
plaisir de vous y rencontrer comptoir de
source
[Applaudissements]
allons allons gérer dit laisse-moi les
hippos tous ne tenait pas dans un état
pareil y'a rien de tragique a dit trouve
la musique et laubman c'est un gamin
j'allais mourir a alors dit papy tease
puis dans une drôle de mélange cir est
une drôle de menace évidemment pauvre
petit shoot tu vas pas t'amuser tous les
jours carette a vu mon nom je peux être
l'avouer raul est le roi des emmerdeurs
quant à sa fille n'y a pas de mots fusil
mois il a l'air de les lâcher avec des
élastiques aux gradins mais aussi à bâle
et 6 des mots dits dont tu vas pas aller
s'enterrer sarreguemines d'égoïste alors
ta jeunesse saboter tout ça pour les
hauts fourneaux mon côté si ça peut être
concerné l'existence avec chorale est
pas rose tous les jours
s'il avoue enfin j'ai tout de suite vu
elle est la pire espèce four bas vont
littéralement fou mais inutile de dire
ça saute aux yeux
ta vieille d'au moins de 10 ans hop tu
trouves figure toi qui hier je me suis
arraché trois cheveux blancs monts
bouchard et ne t'inquiète pas surtout
pour l'inventaire je dirais rien arrivé
dis donc tu tu me pardonnes pour la
gifle
ouais bien sûr et toi pour la chaussure
parce que je ne te pardonne pas c'est
d'avoir manqué raul de si peu c'est
vaudrait rassembleur on aura tout vu
quelques années le bonheur dit tu te
rappelles de megève quand on a été
surpris par la petite anglaise de neige
dans le refuge mais bon avec laquelle
poids était mouillée et à rouspéter
oui oh oui tu m'as manqué le matin
surtout plus personne pour me porter mon
petit déjeuner au lit
salon moi c'était le matin le midi et le
soir c'est vrai géraldine toi aussi tu
sais ton départ a laissé un grand vide
oui moi il frigidaire mais tu fais un
monstre m'avoir abandonner comme ça
pendant cinq mois
non parce que c'est moi qui suis revenu
tu allais de mariée sans même avoir pris
une dernière fois dans tes bras mais tu
y es maintenant tu m'aimes idiote
germain
je te jure que je sais que tu n'as
jamais aimé que moi je te jure j'ai
jamais mais toi encore jamais
complètement ne me quitte pas tu parle
sérieusement
regarde moi géraldine si nous filions
tous les deux sens de cette adresse en
rien maintenant avec moi tout de suite
moi dit si tu veux oui oh oui mon amour
c'est une résistance poids du monde
ah bah ne pourront pas aller très loin
qu'est-ce qui nous arrête rien n'a
changé on n'a pas le sou aussi elle bout
du monde c'est cher même si on dépasse
par centaines l'eau faudra-t-il toujours
se heurter à cette sordide question
d'argent
j'ai eu tort de venir te voir maintenant
ça rend les choses bien difficile a
évidemment nous sommes très engagés
l'année l'eau à tel point qu'il me
semble impossible de revenir en avoir
seulement impossible il faut tenir
jusqu'au bout tiré jusqu'au bout oui il
faudrait pensons à nos enfants car je
pense à nous pour le moment je peux pas
faire un coup pareil à raul utah
semences est entendue il m'adore
je suis son rayon de soleil si j'ai le
plaque et un homme fini ça avec cora ce
serait une véritable tragédie pour nous
et souffrir elle est belle elle est
capable d'entrer au couvent aux normes
pouvant pas non non non non il faut il
faut être humain oh oui mon sa j'adore
j'aime tendre parler ainsi quel sens du
devoir tuer comme moi un oui géraldine
quand on regarde les autres
y'a pas à dire toi et moi on est des
gens biens déjà leurs voix leurs revenus
dès sa sortie sur le sol il n'aura pas
trouvé dans la voiture puis pour une
fois aucun prix tu te vois ici baa à
avaux tunis - les reçoit le who's who
passé a plutôt bien
à
un nom aux enchères ne me dites pas que
vous avez oublié corps à celle héritée
des vous un quart d'heure voilà plus
d'un quart d'heure que je fais du bruit
sur le trottoir dans l'hôtellerie au
point vous étiez un peu en avance
alors je me trouve en haïti bah oui je
me suis mis en retard je lève mon réveil
s'était arrêtée et que quand on se marie
on le droit non deux minutes cora je
vous demande deux minutes pour
m'habiller
aline taille très par dessus la jambe
encore encore fait moi j'en tue souvent
dont nous bien manger je vais d'être
entouré dégâts déjà vous relâchez votre
briquet ne marche jamais il faut
demander des allumettes ou maître
d'hôtel j'ai envie de danser vous voulez
rentrer vous couchez vous bayer pendant
mais dégage
je ne parle pas de l'inadmissible contre
temps de ce matin à l'avenir je serrais
que vous soyez pas trompés sur la
marchandise
j'ai ma dignité d'homme qu'est ce que
vous en faites la sensibilité de femme
ce casque du matin au soir
or à ce genre de remarques très mauvais
goût la note aurait temps on va vous
savez rien quand kombouaré au vestiaire
je dépense de quoi nourrir une femme et
trois enfants
évidemment j'avais pris d'autres
habitudes avec hannibal gens pètent
mais moi je n'ai pas de mine de platine
il est vrai que vous par contre vous
avez des cheveux pas tendre
là aussi à thé cha alors on aura soyez
pas déprimer vous avez eu un petit
mouvement de mauvaise humeur l'a bien
compréhensible mais vous verrez tout ça
ira très bien
un propos qui ne m'a pas du tout celle
apprête à mouches de la grande catherine
je les fait expertiser l efo fonce pour
les voleurs c'est comme pour
l'appartement où j'ai tout décommandé
corps nous n'avons plus besoin de cet
appartement puisque j'ai décidé que nous
allions vivre à bogota à bogota ah non
moi je fais des économies dotées elles
coûtent cher et pendant ce temps là
loterie gagnant ne sert à rien mettant
partons nous par le premier avion j'ai
les billets au bc l'embarquement forcé
pour cythère je vous ai déjà dit je
ferai des économies c'est très gentil
tout ça mais je fini par claquer ses
fruits
voyons manucure 39 ans un journal 80
centimes un dixième de la loterie
nationale 3 thierry oui combien a coûté
le cinéma hier soir mais je sais pas moi
non les 29 francs pour deux orchestres
de pied quand vous avez pris à
l'estrimont géant on ne savent pas je
peux des skis mois de juillet fête et
estimant au cinéma des grandes ouvertes
c'est comme dans un moulin ont-ils pu
passer tous les deux la femme est ce que
c'est que ce bonhomme là
désiré monsieur avant là excusez moi
n'auriez vous pas vu par hasard une
jeune femme en tenue de cheval non
messieurs vous avez dû vous trompez des
tas avant d'user mois un malin
hadji
je suis bien chez monsieur la valette
qui sait cette crise des gens retiennent
quoi encore je ne comprends vraiment
qu'on peut bien être géraldine je lui
demande on attendre en bas je descendais
n'y est pas chirac parce que vous bah
oui madame ça je suis et vous je présume
exactement mes félicitations madame mais
vous de ben monsieur je ne vois pas ce
que l'ex femme de mon futur mari viendra
car ici olivier tu es content tout à
l'heure tiens mais s'est bien gardé de
bâtir trouve monsieur que vous feriez
bien de la visite est un peu là là là là
retenir gestion reggae si vous croyez
c'est toujours facile mais vraiment oui
je sais fota patience obama qui le dites
vous-même ainsi tenez monsieur vous
voyez là sur mon 31 me suis levé aux
aurores pour aller chez le coiffeur le
maire nous attend et ce galopin n'est
même pas fichu d'être à leurs actes il
est vrai que les jeunes femmes affecte
aussi parfois une désinvolture qui
déconcerte sont tous comme ça de nos
jours il fera gagner des pêcheurs itou
de mer sécu millions à la fin oh vous
savez il ne s'en rendent pas compte ils
sont si jeunes
si jeune si jamais ça n'excuse pas tout
oh ça excuse beaucoup quand même madame
sans quoi saurions-nous là vous avez
raison monsieur il faut prendre les
choses avec beaucoup
plus précisément la met brusquement de
profil il me semble que votre
physionomie ne met pas étrangère où nous
serions nous rencontrer peut-être à
l'exposition des dahlias dimanche matin
ah non non je n'y étais pas je n'aime
que les fleurs qui sentent à oui alors
là
je ne vois pas jeter trop 4 samedi
dernier au catch ah non ça je ne vais
jamais au canada d'ailleurs les
occupations ne retiennent dans l'est la
majeure partie de l'année
l'avis de bogota entre bogota et sa
demie n'y a vraiment pas de chance pour
que nos chemins se soit jamais croisés
c'est une erreur
attendez attendez à mon tour j'ai
l'impression que je retrouve dans votre
allure générale quelque chose de
familier
tiens comme c'est étrange non mais nous
sommes certainement tous les deux
victimes d'une quelconque ressemblance
madame je vous ai interrompu dans vos
rencontres je vous prie de m'en excuser
continuer si vous le permettez 9 88 21
et où ces 30
non non non non non non nous basons
excusez moi mais 21 et 11 32 qui ne fait
jamais de faute de calcul ben oui ça
peut arriver
alors je dis donc 21 11 33
non non non
trente deux encore est-ce que je suis
folle 3,3 3.323 mais non madame compter
sur vos doigts vous des ondes
messieurs pas le chiffre 3 3 en
champagne à quoi jouons-nous madame
réfléchissez bien messieurs la ville de
troyes qu'est ce que ça vous rappelle
aline de 3003 attend déjà fait une
période militaire il ya fort longtemps
ça manquait horriblement de distraction
merci vous remercie allez donc vous
casser ce que je pense pour distraire
les troufions vous remercie monsieur on
vous en fichera excusez moi madame si je
vous ai en français on croyait bien que
c'est sans le vouloir mais je ne
comprends toujours pas la revue pendant
le mille avec aura fontaine ça ne vous
rappelle rien cora fontaine set c'était
c'est vous j'espère que vous êtes monté
en grade lieutenant shaga gaza
gaza et je suis capitaine un pain de
réserve
salut mon capitaine oh oh oh corps à
tromper fontaine pardon sur la mer je
n'en crois pas mes yeux commis dans ça
fait combien de temps ça
ce sont elles qui ment vous n'avez pas
changé vous non plus toujours aussi
baratineur huit mois oui je vous ai
attendu depuis si longtemps annonce
pendant deux heures et ça m'a suffi mois
vous m'étonnez alors vous donner un
rendez vous à une femme et vous ne vous
en souvenez pas ah ben je foule il le
faut il met alors la main mais mémoire
est un tunnel obscur on fait la cour
vous m'envoyer des fleurs vous me donner
un rendez-vous
et quand je suis là vous attendre au
café riche devant un ver danese est
toute chamboulée prête à me donner
monsieur me pose la paix le café harris
mémo robert obiwi ce rendez vous vous y
étiez venu fabien stut j'étais venu que
deux remorques de regrets vous me donnez
non c'est fini c'est raté n'en parlons
plus le lendemain reprenant ma tournée
internationale sur prenait le train pour
bar le duc tho et je te dis que tu
oublies me voyez vous si je vous disais
que le lieutenant gars charlie par minc
après de longs à bail
il y avait une épidémie d'oreillons et
toute la caserne était consigné alors
fan est fermé et ben oui je les fais et
c'est justement en le faisant que je me
suis foulé la cheville
on a emmené à l'infirmerie où là aussi
j'ai attrapé les oreillons
si j'avais pu me doutais grand mais je
vous ai écrit toutes les lettres sont
revenus oui j'espère toujours pouvoir
lire votre nom sur une affiche et puis
la vie à la ville à vif aussi peu de
choses pour lui faire changer de
direction
bah oui si j'avais mieux pris mon élan
je voulais faire tomber sur vos pieds
voilà nous nous serions retrouvés ce
soir là tous les deux au cap ferret et
nous serions peut-être à l'heure
actuelle un vieux couple
alors que nous en sommes encore aux
émois des premiers rendez vous normand
riddick
mais pourquoi moi j'ai le coeur battant
comme si je venais de santé il ya
quelques secondes à peine par dessus le
mur de la caserne que vous dites c'est
moi la première qui vous est reconnue et
ben pourtant si je vous disais que
souvent je me suis surpris à fredonner
sept chansons que le public vous pissez
chaque soir laquelle on may be c'est
tout
bien sûr mais particulièrement celle du
final du premier acte qui représentait
attend dé voir le dans l'apothéose des
légumes et des fruits et des frais
auxquels m
ah non c'était parler du c'était en
chicorée frisée
et bien lieu avec quelques 2,5 et
l'audace avec l emprunt vous lancez
votre public ces couples et sans que
toute la salle
aussi vous savez bien attendaient des
gestes avec des gestes de gamines ont
démontré ces salles et dans les rues de
buenos aires vous les autres freins dans
sa corbeille l on choisissait et à
l'oreille elle vous glisser trois
premiers est morte à vivre
pour tous
[Applaudissements]
à moi ça où s'activent
j'irai lui été blessé
pour finir je vous ai grandi car oui tu
as raison mon nom les avait complètement
oublié
tu entends j'ai 1 din oui c'était pas
très bien comment elle prend corps avez
vous y retrouver toute ma jeunesse toute
ma gaieté
merci parce que grâce à vous pendant
quelques années ce temps je me suis cru
encore la chicorée retour des choses pas
au final et on y va
oui ça va mieux y voyons dépêchons-nous
à la réflexion un petit qui jeûne dans
simple du tout non jeanne mance un plus
pour le mariage par exemple vous ne vous
fâchez pas tu aurais voyons vous le
savez aussi bien être moi moi vous étiez
un caprice pour vous je n'étais que la
raison vous auriez pu vous avez
percevoir plus tôt vous attend ah oui
pardonnez moi j'ai envie de même aussi
de mon côté j'ai quelque chose à te dire
tiens si oui voilà j'arrive aux eps à
doha mais il ya un mais voilà vous
l'avez deviné il est taillé je vous
assomme je vous assomme alors pour ne
pas vous infliger plus longtemps à
pareil calvaire bien j'ai décidé de
partir tout seul pour sarreguemines une
plaque thiery qui va faire quelque chose
monsieur n'abandonne pas de cette façon
une jeune femme seule dans la vie
nouveau disponible ils se foutent de
nous du marché on dirait oui de mes
enfants c'est une petite bavure du
destin nous avons voulu et quart plus
vite que lui et puis
atayi fait un gros match voilà la
question n'est pas là j'ai perdu mon
temps j'ai eu des frais de
représentation
là une promesse de mariage les bains ont
été publiés en bouchard ne me dites pas
que je vous ai fait un enfant j'ai
d'immenses et pour vous j'ai fait
souffrir mon mari pour vous vous m'avez
compromise moi j'appelle ça de la plus
confiance en l'homme et enfants
d'employés pas des mots dont vous
ignorez le sens maillot rose on n'en
avez-vous pas d'arbre moins que vous
n'avez une platine madame et messieurs
cachard 2 millions seriez-vous riches
c'est à dire que je ne suis pas à
plaindre mais vous même corps à vous
possédez du platine nuit mon chef des
mines de platine des grattes vient dé
finalement eu quelques petites babioles
en plus alors qu aura désormais il ne
tiendra qu'à vous l'avoir aussi des
tuyaux décidément raul c'est ma d'estivé
que d'être aimé par des hommes riches
n'ont pas ici pas chez nous venez venez
à l'amérique s'est vite non non non il
faut que jacques décommandé loubert amer
ce n'est pas n'importe qui vous allez
encore un et puis nous pourrions
peut-être avoir besoin lui ne pas vous
fier monde où je vous l'avais dit joe
papp
cet argent semble c'est à vomir sert à
quoi d'être jeune beau et intelligent
ils ont bien fait marcher et alors toi
et tes milliardaire pas sûr parce que
j'étais obligé de savoir qui nous
mettrait son à times matt white noise
même plus la parole c'est ça fait
l'esprit fou ce que ça peut coûter cher
mais enrichie avec eux on n'en a pas
pour notre argent
thiery qu'est ce qu'on va faire ouvrons
utc mourrons ensemble comme ça il y aura
plus de problème j'ai envie de vivre un
mois
bien des toits oui tu as raison mon
amour
d'ailleurs le buzz est coupée ben tu
vois ça ronge
vivant non ou plutôt en essayant mais
alors qu'est ce que tu proposes et si
seulement j'avais encore ma machine à
écrire c'est vrai on n'aura que la
revendre
non non je me serai remis à mon scénario
ah oui évidemment et à ton scénario ah
oui c'est idiot tarder tous capital dans
ma tête et moi j'aurais appris à taper
sténodactylo secrétaire rédactrice
dommage mais aussi les très belles idées
de romans et pourquoi pas une pièce de
théâtre thierry aussi m chiche au
travail et ce doit être tellement moins
fatigant que de ne rien faire
oui et puis ça nous changera quoi que ça
m'amuse à un investissement et commencer
tout de suite si on donnait à tocane
faut pas prendre pour célébrer notre
champ dollon j'aurais dit non plus
incorrigible
oui enfin aujourd'hui c'est bien je ne
pus ordinateur fusée je t'adore faisons
la vista alors preuve rien que les
intimes oui à plus de 50 personnes bon
on va inviter jean charles lemuria 8h15
homme n'aura qu'à bien sûr bob l'oiseau
un nom un nombre à vol d'oiseau
ah non non non je préfère ne pas
travailler je préfère ne pas donner de
toi que celle du tout plutôt que
d'inviter cet abruti allons bon
tout allait très bien pourvu que ce soit
pas un avis il nous aurait prévenu tout
de même annoncé le télégramme qu'il
annonce moi j'aime bien me trouver nez à
nez avec le télégramme qu'elle
conservait le nez à nez avec avec elle
si rooney man résistance est à coup sûr
un peu plus maintenant au marché vous
mais quelle bonne surprise entre et mes
amis vous êtes les bienvenus j'espère
que vous n'avez pas changé d'avis au
moins mais non non non rassurez vous on
parce que nous vous savez on se rend
mardi et c'est définitive et nous
inspire aussi définitive nous nous
marierons tous les quatre ensemble
enfin je veux dire deux par deux le même
jour
et vous serez noté mois voilà donc mais
oui nous sommes d'abord monté pour obama
et puis ensuite pour vous prévenir de
cela alors nous allons passer à la
mairie pour fixer le jour de la
cérémonie et ensuite je vous invite tous
à déjeuner à la carpe d'or tient aux
credo
vous excuserez maintenu - dont vous êtes
l'auteur avoué d'un chou comme ça et
vous même le roussi aura passé gérald
genest a dépêché maintenant moi j'ai une
faim de loup
ces pousses que l'amour creuse john a
oui vous vous souvenez de ce chèque que
vous m'aviez données non pas du tout si
pour me rembourser des enfants j'avais
avancé à géraldine
ah oui alors eh bien alors je n'ai
jamais pu le toucher parce que vous
aviez promis de ne signez pas possible
oui mais je ne vous en veux pas vous
savez ça peut arriver à tout le monde
donc et c'est bien entendu je vous
invite à dijon
merci oui et naturellement c'est vous
qui paierez l'addition impartialement
seynois et ben décidément vous mettre
très sympathique jeune homme
la pièce que nous venons de jouer pour
vous et de barillet et grédy
la mise en scène de jacques crs
décor de rosé art
mes robes et costumes de donald cardwell
avec martin kelly
philippe bénesse
suzy delair
les jacques morel
[Musique]